สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้าสวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนครูฟ้าวัน
นี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้วันจันทร์ค่ะวันที่
เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
6 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ 25  566 เอ้อ
ขอบคุณค่ะครู
ฟ้ามีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะเมื่อ
วานนี้วัน
อาทิตย์วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่
5 เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2566 ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะพรุ่งนี้
วัน
อังคารวันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 7 เดือน
อะไรคะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพ.ศอะไรคะปีพ.ศ 2566
ปีค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ
2023 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้กี่โมงคะครูฟ้าตอนนี้
เวลา 10:00 น 10 นกี่นาที 5 นทีค่ะค่ะ 105
นวันนี้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยตื่นนอนกี่โมงวันนี้
ครูฟ้าตื่นนอน 900
น 9 น 99:00 นตรงเลยหรอคะ
930 นาทีอ๋อ 9:30 นนี่ครูฟ้าตื่นนอนแล้ว
เมื่อคืนครูฟ้าเนี่ยนอนกี่โมงเมื่อคืนครู
ฟ้านอน 3:00
ค่ะ
3:00  3:00 นตรงเลยใช่มั้ย 3:00 นเท่า
ไหร่ 3:00 น
3  35 ประมาณอ่ะก็ 3:30 นก็ได้จะได้คิด
ง่ายๆนะคะ 3:30 น 430 น 5:30 น 6:30 น
7:30 น 88:30 น 9:30 นครูฟ้าเนี่ยนอน 6
ช่วโมง
6 ชมมอนี้เยอะนอน 6 ช่มหรือนอนโอเคมยเออ
โอเค
มยน้อยไปมั้ย
ก็ก็ไม่น้อยมาก
ไม่ได้น้อยมากแต่น้อยอืก็ยังนอนน้อยแต่
ครูฟ้านอน 3:30 นเนี่ยอันนี้ไม่โอเค 100%
นะคะอครูฟ้าไม่ได้นะครูฟ้าจะคิดว่าครูฟ้า
เนี่ยนอน 6 ชมงเนี่ยโอเคเพราะว่าเรานอน 6
ถึง 8 ชมงอันนี้กำลังดีใช่มั้ยคะครูฟ้า
นอน 6 ชมมเนี่ยโอเคแล้วแต่แต่ครูฟ้าเนี่ย
เข้านอน 3:30 นอันเนี้ยไม่ดีไม่ดีกับร่าง
กายของเรานอน 3:30 นไม่ดี
เหรอไม่ดีค่ะครูฟ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยต้อง
นอนก่อน 22:00
นอืถ้าครูฟ้านอน 22:00 นโอเคหรือว่านอน
ก่อน 22:00 นใช่มยคะ 21:00
นอันเนี้ยดีกับร่างกายเราเนี่ยพอ 22:00 น
แล้วครูฟ้าหรือว่าครูหญิงหรือนักเรียน
เนี่ยเราต้องนอนได้แล้ว 22:00 นเร็วไป
มั้ย
เนี่ยอ่ะถ้าครูฟ้ารู้สึกว่า 22:00 นเร็ว
ไปก็อย่างน้อยอ่ะ 23
น 2300 นครูฟ้าก็ต้องนอนเพราะถ้าครูฟ้า
นอนเที่ยงค
คืต
1 อื 2
อูถ้า 1:00 นแล้ว 2:00 นแล้วครูฟ้านอน
เนี่ยก็ไม่ดีกับกับร่างกายแล้วนะอืยิ่ง
3:30 นเนี่ยไม่ดีมากๆครูฟ้ามันจะไม่ดี
กับหัวใจของครูฟ้านะนอนดึกดีกับหัวใจเหรอ
คะครูหญิงเ้าหัวใจครูฟ้าต้องตึกๆตึๆๆกๆๆๆ
หัวใจจครูฟ้าเนี่ยเต้นทุกวัน
เต้น 24 ชมงทุกวันทุกวันทุกวันอืถ้าครู
ฟ้าครูฟ้าลองลองดูสิถ้า 3:00 น 2:00  1 น
เนี่ยครูฟ้ายังไม่นอนหัวใจของครูฟ้าเนี่ย
มันจะเต้นตึกๆๆๆๆๆๆๆๆๆๆๆๆๆเต้นเร็วๆนะ
เต้นเร็วๆเลยเหรอคะผู้หญิงใช่เห็นมั้ยไม่
ดีกับร่างกายแต่ถ้าครูฟ้านอน 22:00 นอัน
นี้เนี่ยดีกับร่างกายดีกับหัวใจอือได้ค่ะ
ครูหญิงเดี๋ยวครูฟ้าจะลองนอน 22:00 นนะคะ
ได้ค่ะแต่ว่าวันนี้เนี่ยครูหญิงก็ยังมี
เรื่องอื่นอาจจะเป็นเรื่องอาหารชีวิตของ
เราในทุกๆวันว่าเราทำอันนี้ดีหรือไม่ดีดี
กับร่างกายให้ครูฟ้าคิดจริงๆบางครั้งบาง
อย่างมันอาจจะดีบางอย่างถ้าเราคิดมันอาจ
จะไม่ดีแต่มันอาจจะดีก็ได้ไม่รู้นะคะลอง
ไปดูกันได้ค่ะน่าอันนี้อร่อยใช่มยคะใช่
ค่ะุหญิงอันนี้มีอะไรบ้างเนี่ยโหอันนี้มี
เนช fr มีโอเนียนริงนะคะมีไก่ทอดไก่ทอด
ไก่ทอดอันนี้อะไร
อ่ะ
เปล่าเออไม่รู้เหมือนกันนะครูฟ้าก็เป็น
ปลานะคะนักเรียนนนักเกตอ่าแต่ทั้งหมดนี้
นะคะทั้งหมดนี้เนี่ยเราเรียกว่าของทอดอื
เพราะว่าเขาคก็จะมีกระทะใช่มั้ยคะแล้วก็
ใส่น้ำมันแล้วก็มีไฟแล้วก็เอาเฟรนช์ไฟฟาย
ลงไปแล้วก็ของ
ทอดอร่อยใช่ค่ะุหญิงครูฟ้าชอบกิน
เฟรนช์ฟรายมากครูฟ้าตื่นเลยนะคะนักเรียน
ครูฟ้าเห็นของทอดจริงๆครูหญิงชอบโอเนียน
ริงมากเลยนะครูฟ้าโอเนียนริงก็อร่อยไก่
ทอดก็ชอบเบสีนะคะใช่ค่ะครูฟ้าคะเราชอบเรา
คิดว่าของทอดเนี่ยอร่อยเวลากินใช่มยอื
อร่อยแต่ของของทอดเนี่ยดีกับร่างกายเราย
คะหรือว่าไม่ดีกับร่างกายของเราแน่นอนนะ
คะของทอดเนี่ย
ดีไม่ใช่ครูฟ้าของทอดเอาวาดยังไงล่ะมือ
อ่ะวาดตามมือครูฟ้าแล้วกันนะ 2  3  4 ดี
กับร่างกายของเราเนี่ยกี่
เปอร์เซ็นต์ดีกับร่างกายของ
เรา
120% ไม่ใช่ค่ะดีกับร่างกายของเราเนี่ย
0% ต้องไม่
ดีไม่ดีหรออันนี้ถูกมยอ่าเห็นมยไม่ดีค่ะ
ครู
ฟ้าทำไมของทอดเนี่ยมีคอเลสเตอรอลเยอะๆ
ไม่ดีกับร่างกายไม่ดีกับหัวใจอื
คอเลสเตอรอลเนี่ยกินแล้วไม่ดีกับหัวใจหรอ
คะใช่ค่ะใช่มเพราะว่าหัวใจของนักเรียน
เนี่ยมันจะ
มีอันนี้ดูหัวใจเนาะหัวใจใช่มั้ยหัวใจเรา
มันจะมีเท่าไหร่เนี่ย 1  2 ผู้หญิงวาดถูก
มั้ยถูกแล้วเข้างล่างข้างบนเออครูหญิงวาด
ผิดนะคะนักเรียนใช่มั้ยหัวใจของเราเนี่ย
มันจะมี
1  2
3  4 ใช่มอันนี้หัวใจเนาะหัวใจที่นี่ก็
จะมีเลือดใช่มยสีแดงๆเนาะมีเลือดติ๊ก
เลือดที่เป็นกรุ๊ป a
a กรุ๊ป B แล้วก็กรุ๊ป O ใช่มั้ยเลือด
ของเราเนี่ยถ้าครูฟ้ากินของทอดเนี่ย
ในเลือดของครูฟ้าก็จะมีคอเลสเตอรอล
คอเลสเตอรอลคอเลสเตอรอลอืหัวใจครูฟ้าก็
ไม่ดีก็หัวใจไม่ดีเลือดไม่ดีร่างกายก็ไม่
ดีแต่ถ้าครูฟ้ากินแล้วครูฟ้าเนี่ยวิ่งๆๆๆ
เต้น
แอโรบิกก็อาจจะโอเคมั้งอือๆๆๆแต่แต่ของ
ทอดไม่ดีกับร่างกายค่ะครูฟ้ายังไงก็ไม่ดี
หรอคะใช่ค่ะอ่ะครูฟ้าแล้วถ้าเป็นผลไม้ล่ะ
คะผลไม้เนี่ยกินแล้วดีกับร่างกายหรือว่า
ไม่ดีกับร่างกายผลไม้เนี่ยนะคะกิน
แล้วดีกับร่างกาย
ค่ะทั้งหมดเลยไหม
สับปะรดส้มกีวี่กุกล้วยมะพร้าวแอปเปิ้ลสา
อันนี้อะไรเนี่ยสาแอปเปิ้ลเหมือนกันนะคะ
เลมอน
องุ่น
เนาะใช่ค่ะคิดว่าทุกอย่างดีกับร่างกายนะ
คะดีกับร่างกายทั้งหมดเลยอืว่าผลไม้มี
วิตามินใช่มั้ยคะหรือว่าไวตามินเนาะกิน
แล้วดีกับร่างกายนะคะอ่ะแล้วถ้าอันนี้ไม่
ได้กินนะคะนักเรียนสูบบุหรี่ล่ะ
คะสูบบุหรี่เนี่ยดีกับร่างกายหรือว่าไม่
ดีกับร่างกายสูบบุหรี่เนี่ยนะ
คะไม่ดีกับร่างกายค่ะ่เออใช่แล้วถ้าเรา
สูบบุหรี่สูบบุรี่สูบบุหรี่มากๆไม่ดีกับ
ส่วนไหนในร่างกายคะครูฟ้าสูบบุหรี่เนี่ย
นะคะไม่ดีกับปอดค่ะอืครูฟ้าวาดปอดได้มั้ย
คะเพราะูหญิงวาดไม่ได้ปอดวาดยัง
ไงวาดหัวเราะแบบแกล้งครูฟ้านะคะ 2 อัน
อยู่ตรงนี้
มั้ยอันนั้นอะไรคะเส้นๆ
เอ่อ
หลอดหลอดลงมันเป็นแบบนี้
มั้ยป่อต้องยาวๆนี้มครูฟ้าเออปล่อยครูฟ้า
น่ารักนะอันนี้หลอดลมใช่มยใช่
ค่ะเบอกกูอ่ะประมาณนี้มั้งไม่รู้อ่ะไม่
รู้นะคะนักเรียนรูให้นักเรียนดูมั้ยคะ
โปรดได้ค่ะเนี่ยนะคะอ่าถ้าเราสูบบุหรี่
บุหรี่เนี่ยมีควันใช่มั้ยมีควันควันควัน
บุหรี่ก็จะจะอยู่ในปอดในปอดของเราอ่านี่
คือปอดเอก็ได้อยู่นะคะนัก
เรียนอ่ะนี่นะคะปอดเห็นมั้ยถ้าเราสูบ
บุหรี่เนี่ยไม่ดีกับร่างกายไม่ดีกับปอดนะ
คะอือ่ะแล้วเราดื่มน้ำผลไม้ล่ะคะดีหรือ
ว่าไม่ดีกับร่างกายคะครูฟ้าดื่มน้ำผลไม้
เนี่ยนะคะก็เหมือนกับผลไม้ใช่มั้ยคะนัก
เรียนเราดื่มเนี่ยเนี่ยเหมือนกับผลไม้อ่า
ผลไม้เนี่ยดีกับร่างกายนะคะครูฟ้าก็คิด
ว่าดื่มน้ำผลไม้ก็ดีกับร่างกายมยใช่ค่ะ
ถ้าเราดื่มน้ำผลไม้น้ำส้มน้ำกีวี่น้ำ
สตรอเบอร์รี่
100% ดีแต่ถ้ามีน้ำส้ม
20% อีก 80% เนี่ยเป็นน้ำ
ตาล
ใช่น้ำตาลหวานๆนะค่ะนักเรียนน้ำตาลก็จะมี
มีมดใช่
ไหมเนี่ย
มดมดเนี่ยมดๆๆๆๆเนี่ยถ้ามีน้ำตาลอันนี้ก็
ไม่ดีกับร่างกายนะคะถ้ามีน้ำผลไม้แค่ 20%
เนาะอ่ะต่อไปนะคะครูฟ้าค่ะ
ถ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยนอนดู
คอมพิวเตอร์เล่นเกมนอนฟังเพลงแบบ
นี้แล้วก็กินพิซซ่ากินไก่นะคะนี่ไงเล่น
เกมพิซซ่า 1 วันเนี่ยมี 24 ชมงครูฟ้านอน
เล่นเกมแบบนี้ซัก 18
ชมงอืไม่เดินไม่ลุกขึ้นมาอันนี้ดีกับร่าง
กายหรือว่าไม่ดีกับร่างกายคะแน่นอนนะคะ
ว่ากินพิซซ่า
เนี่ยอร่อย
เอ้ยไม่ได้ให้ดูพิซซ่าค่ะให้ดูว่าผู้ชาย
คนนี้เนี่ยเานอนเล่นเกมทั้งวันเลยอืไม่
ขยับไม่เดินไม่อันนี้เค้านอนใช่มั้ยไม่
ไม่ยืนเนี่ยยืนก็ไม่ยืนอันนี้ดีหรือไม่ดี
กับร่างกายครูฟ้าแบบนี้ก็
ต้องไม่ดีกับร่างกายใช่มั้ยคะครูหญิงใช่
ค่ะอันนี้ไม่ดีเนาะเราต้องผู้ชายเขาต้อง
ลุกขึ้นแล้วก็ยืนแล้วก็เดินบ้างเดินเดินๆ
ดินเอถ้านอนแบบนี้ไม่ดีนะครูหญิงกับครู
ฟ้าเนี่ยนั่งนะคะนักเรียนเพราะว่าเรามี
เก้าอี้อืนี้ก็คนหญิงนะคะแล้วก็มี
คอมพิวเตอร์ที่นี่อืโอเคมยคะเรา
นั่งนี่
ไม่นี่ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้านั่งทำงานอยู่ข้าง
หน้า
คอมพิวเตอร์ใช่วันละ 10 ช่วโมง
10 ชมงเลยเหรอเอออันนี้ดีหรือไม่ดีกับ
ร่างกายคะอันนี้เนี่ย 10 ชมงเนี่ยไม่ดี
กับร่างกายใช่มั้ยคะไม่ดีอเออแล้วกี่
ชั่วโมงอ่ะถึงจะโอเคดีกับร่างกายคิดว่า
น่าจะประมาณ 3-4 ชมงแล้วก็เบรคมลุกขึ้น
เดินเดินเดิน
อืเ 10
ชมง 10 ชมงไม่เบรคเลยอันนี้ไม่ดีใช่ไหมม
คะไม่ดีค่ะไม่ดีนี้ก็อาจจะเบรคสัก 30
นาทีใชม
เดินเพราะว่าถ้าเรานั่งนานๆแล้วก็ดู
คอมพิวเตอร์เนี่ยมันไม่ดีกับร่างกายแล้ว
ก็ยังไม่ดีกับตาใช่มั้ยคะตาของเราอแล้วก็
หลังเหลังเนี่ย
โอปวดปวดหลังนะคะนเรียน
อืเอ่ะถ้าเราอูอันนี้เนี่ยขนมหวานนะคะขนม
หวานไม่ว่าจะเป็น
ไอศครีม
มาชเมลโลลูก
อมลูกอมอมยิ้มเนี่ยนะคะเยนลี่ทั้งหมด
เนี่ยคือขนมหวานถ้าเรากินขนมหวานมาก
ๆหรือว่ากินนิดหน่อยหรือว่ากินทุกวันวัน
จันทร์ถึงวันอาทิตย์เนี่ยกินิกินทุกวัน
เนี่ยพวกขนมหวานเนี่ยดีหรือว่าไม่ดีกับ
ร่างกายคะครูฟ้าพวกขนมหวานเนี่ยนะคะครู
ฟ้าคิด
ว่าครูฟ้ายิ้มนะคะนักเรียนครูฟ้าชอบนะคะ
รักทุกคนชอบทุกคนชอบแต่ขนมหวานไม่ดีกับ
ร่างกายค่ะครูหญิงใช่มยมันหวานมากๆนะคะ
แล้วก็มันมีสีเห็นมยสีเขี้ยวๆสีแดงแดง
อย่างเงี้ยสีก็ไม่ดีแล้วมันก็หวานเนาะไม่
ดีกับร่างกายไม่ดีกับฟันฟันด้วยใช่ถ้า
เป็นเด็กๆใช่ไหมมอายุ 3 ถึง 10 ขวบกินขนม
หวานมากๆก็ฟันก็ไม่โอเคนะคะไม่ดีต้องถ้า
ทุกอย่างผู้หญิงคิดว่ากินนิดหน่อยเนี่ย
น่าจะโอเคใช่ค่ะใช่ทุกอย่างูฟ้าชอบกิน
เยลลี่มากๆนะคะนี่ใช่มยคะครูฟ้าเยลลี่
เยลลี่ใช่เยลลี่นี่ก็เยลลี่นะคะเยลลี่นี่
ก็เยลลี่เออนัก็เยลลี่เห็นมอร่อยแต่ไม่ดี
นะคะนี่ทำงานใช่มทุเรียนเหรอคะครูฟ้า
ทุเรียนกินทุเรียนเนี่ยเอาถ้านักเรียน 1
วันนักเรียนเนี่ยมาประเทศไทยใช่ไหมนัก
เรียนเนี่ยนั่งเครื่องบินแล้วก็ฟู้ประเทศ
ไทยนักเรียนก็อยากกิน
ทุเรียนแต่ถ้านักเรียนเนี่ยกินอาหารคลีน
ไงนักเรียนชอบนักเรียนไม่กินอาหารไม่ดี
กับร่างกายแล้วนักเรียนก็อยากรู้ว่า
ทุเรียนเนี่ยกินแล้วดีดีกับร่างกายหรือ
ว่าไม่ดีไม่ดีกับร่าง
กายทุเรียนเนี่ยเป็นผลไม้ใช่มเป็นผลไม้
ผลไมเออเหมือนแอปเปิ้ลใช่มั้คะ
สตอเบอร์รี่บลูเบอร์รี่กล้วยอ่า
ผลไม้งั้นครูฟ้าบอกว่าผลไม้เนี่ยกินแล้ว
ดีกับร่างกายน้ำผลไม้ใช่ไหมยดื่มดื่มน้ำ
ส้มน้ำแอปเปิ้ลก็ดีกับร่างกายทุเรียนก็
เป็นผลไม้ถ้าเรากินทุเรียนก็ดีกับร่าง
กาย
ใช่
มยไม่ใช่นะไม่ใช่หรอเอ้าก็ครูฟ้าบอกว่า
ทุเรียนเป็นผลไม้นี่เรากินผลไม้ผลไม้ดี
กับร่างกายแล้วทำทำไมทุเรียนไม่ดีกับร่าง
กายล่ะกคิดว่าทุเรียนเนี่ยนะคะมันมี
ซัลเฟอร์เยอะมอืใช่แล้วก็ฟอร์ไข่
คอเลสเตอรอลมยคอเลสเตอรอลด้วยแล้วทุเรียน
เนี่ยก็เป็นผลไม้ที่ร้อน
อืร้อนเหมือนพระอาทิตย์ใช่
มยใช่ค่ะเซเฟอร์นั่นแหละที่เรากินิินเข้า
ไปนะคะูหญิงคิดว่าถ้าครูฟ้าหรือหรือนัก
เรียนเนี่ยกินทุเรียน 1 ูอันเนี้ยเรา
เรียกว่า 1 พูนะคะ 1 ูแต่ไม่ใช่ 1 วันวัน
จันทร์ 1 ูวันอังคาร 1 ูวันพุธ 1 ูอันนี้
ไม่ได้นะคะก็ 1 วัน 1 ูไงไม่ได้มันก็เยอะ
ไปไงกินทุกวันเออแต่ถ้านักเรียนแบบอาซัก 3
วันมย 3 วันกิน 1 ูเนี่ย 1 ู
ก็อาจจะโอเคอ่าแต่ถ้านักเรียนเนี่ยกิน 1
ลูก 1 คนกินทุเรียน 1 ลูกแล้วก็ไม่ใช่ 3
วัน 1
วันอันนี้มันมากเกินไปเนาะไม่ดีไม่โอเค
หรอคะไม่โอเคค่ะนักเรียนจะรู้สึกมันร้อน
นะคะร้อนข้างในอ่ากินคือของบางอย่างเนี่ย
อย่างทุเรียนใช่่มยกินนิดหน่อยดีกับร่าง
กายกินมากๆไม่ดีกับร่างกายเหมือนเหมือน
กาแฟไงกาแฟเนี่ยดื่ม 1 แก้วใช่ม 1 แก้ว
เนี่ย
โอเคดีกับร่างกายแต่ถ้า 1 วันดื่ม 4 แก้ว
5 แก้วขึ้นไปอเนี้ยไม่ดีกับร่างกายใช่ม
ก็อยู่ที่ว่าอะไรนะคะแต่สำหรับครูหญิงกับ
ครูฟ้าอะไรที่ไม่ดีกับร่างกายกินแล้ว
อร่อยอร่อยก็ต้องเลือกนะคะนักเรียนกิน
อร่อยหรือดีกับร่างกายไม่รู้เนาะอันนี้
แล้วแต่นะคะส่วนวดีโอนี้ครูหญิงกับครูฟ้า
ไปก่อนนะคะแล้วเรามาเจอกันใหม่วีดีโอหน้า
สวัสดีค่ะส่ะ
[เพลง]